[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes from
spectator tv
silicon valley has established itself as
the biggest player
in american politics in the wake of last
week's capitol hill riot
so we'll explore the power of the big
tech units
in the age of social media we'll speak
to professor francois balu a geneticist
at university college london who can
shed light
on the new strains of sars cove ii and
the origins of the virus
particularly timely this week as the
whose investigators
arrive in china and on the rollout of
vaccines we'll turn to israeli
journalist
and shall feffer to break down exactly
how israel has
seemingly done so well and what it means
for
benjamin netanyahu's re-election
prospects
and of course we'll have our usual
spectator tv
hit with our political editors james
forsythe
and katie balls on hand to update us
on the latest from westminster now
remember if you subscribe
to the spectator's youtube channel for
free
you'll never miss another episode just
click the subscribe
button at the bottom right of the screen
now a very special thanks to charles
stanley for their continued support
of the week in 60 minutes charles
stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms one of
the oldest companies on
london stock exchange we're delighted to
be partners
now it's been just over a week since the
storming of capitol hill
by pro trump mob and what a week it's
been
president trump has been impeached for
the second time
that's a first for any sitting president
but twitter youtube
and facebook have all suspended his
accounts
many of his followers then moved to
parlor an alternative social media
platform
but apple and google quickly removed
parlor from their app stores
and amazon web services removed parlour
from its cloud
effectively that deleted the platform
from the internet
silicon valley has never quite flexed
its muscles in this way before
which is why it is on this week's
spectator cover
i'm joined again by amber athe the
spectators washington editor and also by
peter greenberger
former head of political advertising at
twitter
and google peter let me come to you
first you once said that you were proud
of twitter's
uh commitment to free speech are you
still proud of it
i am i am proud of of what the company
has created over the last decade or so
creating
a platform where people from all walks
of life whether you're an elected
official
or an everyday citizen can have your
voice heard
and to be able to read and comment on
and
and share uh what other people are
saying
i am also proud of what they've done
just recently i don't think this is
something they took lightly i don't
think this is something they ever wanted
to do
and as jack dorsey has said just
recently
he sees this as a failure actually on
their part
that they weren't able to maintain a
healthy conversation i disagree
i think it's a larger societal and
electoral and and even
governmental failure but still i think
their hand was forced
but are you comfortable with the idea
that who should be on twitter or
facebook or others
can be decided by a couple of
billionaires in silicon valley i i
recognize
again this is not ideal it's not a place
where we wanted to be or where these
companies wanted to be but i think
what you have to understand is that this
is not necessarily
a question of the first amendment or a
question of free speech it's
it's a question of choice and ultimately
these companies
made the choice that they no longer
wanted to
assist in the dissemination or the
hosting
of information that they saw as first of
all false as misinformation but also as
dangerous
and which which certainly led to uh in
large part led to
what happened at the u.s capitol on
wednesday so mr trump has been
suspended we think uh for life um
because he was seen by them to be
inciting violence leading to these
appalling scenes on capitol hill
but on twitter there is still a hashtag
kill trump
and a hashtag assassinate trump and one
of the tweets that goes with that
hashtag tag is
someone take this clown are you mr trump
take him out now these are all still on
twitter
why if it violates their terms and
conditions they should bring it down and
i
certainly haven't read or can't i can't
defend every tweet but
they have terms and conditions which up
until recently
there was this carve out uh under the
under under the newsworthiness label for
heads of state to be able to tweet
pretty much what they wanted and i
as you mentioned i had defended that for
many years when i worked there
and when i left i think it is most times
better to know what your leader is
thinking than to have to guess
uh and in fact we now are in that
position where we hear that he is
uh raging around an empty west wing and
we're not quite sure what's on his mind
perhaps it would be better to know but i
will say his behavior has improved
markedly
now that he has lost his favorite toy it
i'm not i mean there is a case against
what twitter
and others have done but that's not the
case i'm putting to you it's the
consistency
it's the criteria i mean some people
will find it strange that mr trump
has been banned for life from twitter
but the ayatollah in iran is still
able to tweet his bile against israel
talking about how the regime will perish
i think what they've done with trump
however now opens the door for them to
take
further action which again is not where
they wanted to be but
now that they have taken this very very
dramatic important step i think they can
look
harder at the policies that they've had
again the terms and conditions have been
that ordinary users you and i cannot use
the platform to threaten violence
uh or or incite violence against other
people
foreign leaders however have been able
to tweet pretty much what they want
this is what crossed the line should it
have been uh
you know the khomeini should have been
somebody else perhaps
but this is the time when they felt they
had to make the decision i will say that
they there has always been this
complaint that it falls harder on
certain segments
the fact is going away from from iran
back to the united states conservatives
in particular feel like
they're being picked on when you look at
who's violating the terms and conditions
it's one side violating the terms and
conditions at a much higher rate than
the other side
those are the accounts that have been
taken hold on let's have a look at that
because after we know
that black lives matter used twitter and
facebook to organize
uh their demonstrations many of which
ended in riot and violence
in portland and seattle not one of them
was closed down
there's a twitter account called pigs in
a blanket
fry em like bacon eggs in a blanket
crime like bacon's referring to the
police it's a call
to kill police that twitter account is
still
up as well yeah people can incite
violence and twitter has done
nothing about it i i would disagree
again i would say on the main
it it's it's a bit like whack-a-mole
there are millions of accounts tweeting
out millions of pieces of information
every day when things are flagged and
things clearly violate the terms and
conditions they make an effort to take
them down
again there's been this accusation that
it's based on partisanship
when studies have been done they have
seen that more people are making
violations on the right there is a
segment of the population in the united
states
that believes things that are that are
completely
untrue and it's because the leaders of
the country the elected officials of the
country and some main conservative
outlets pedal in this lunacy
even just the other day you had a member
of congress
refuse to admit who's going to be the
next president or that he was elected
rightfully
we had an election it was as transparent
as every other election we've ever had
and yet for some reason certain members
of the government refuse to acknowledge
it and they're inciting this madness
so there are different levels i think of
misinformation
and it's hard to pinpoint we had a
justice potter here
who said uh when defining something else
i'll know it when i see it and i think
finally twitter decided
they knew it when they saw it
information that they no longer wanted
to host on their platform
can you give any examples of uh the
black lives
matter uh organizers uh
using social media to organize what
became violent protests can you give any
examples of them
being taken down i don't have them handy
i'm sure they did take down uh
organizations and people that have cited
violence on the other side
the fact is though that they haven't ex
incited this type of violence it's just
a mistruth
and this uh comparison black lives
matter have not incited any violence
fashion as the president of the knights
president of the united states giving a
speech
to what essentially was an angry mob and
directing them to the united states
capital
people marched in the streets to provide
rights for people that have not
had equal rights in this country for 400
years
and that's just a different matter so
the people who
have caused the consistent violence in
seattle and in portland are in a
different category than those who caused
the violence in capitol hill last week
i i condemn all violence as everyone has
but yes i would put it in a different
category actually
but either way twitter needs to enforce
their rules equally and i think now that
they've taken this action against the
president
they will take a harder look at not only
other foreign other leaders other
people in power but also other
organizations who use the platform
was it right to ban links
uh to the new york post story about
hunter biden
that was a very difficult uh choice for
them to make and
and that that's something that i think
people can certainly debate freely i
think that the company themselves
uh took a step back from that and and
and recognized that maybe that was not
the best decision that they made
uh but that's a hard question for them
to answer and i think that's what all
these social media companies and news
organizations have to answer for
what i'll say is that we have all
learned a lot from 2016. there were
cable networks
who aired then candidate trump's speak
rally speeches from start to finish well
before he was a front-runner
uh because it made great tv now when he
is speaking at the lectern in the white
house press briefing room
there are cable networks that will go
away from him if he starts
uh speaking missed troops that's a
mistruth that's a remarkable change
similarly the social media companies
would
publish and post and share anything and
everything related to the election
under the guise of sticking to freedom
of expression four or five years ago
now they're putting some limits on that
so do you allow stories to spread that
are blatantly mistrue is the first
question
but of course a very important question
as you raise is
who who's the arbiter of truth and these
companies have said that they do not
want to be the arbiter of truth
but the problem is there is no arbiter
of truth and that's what we're figuring
out
uh even if you're an elected official it
turns out you can say whatever
helps you raise money and grift off your
offer your supporters
in a sense it's an issue of who gods are
the guardians and i'll come back to that
in a minute let me bring amber in now
surely it's only right that companies
like twitter
and facebook and others they
should not have an obligation to publish
disinformation
and incitement to violence
yeah i think that's a fair statement
however the problem with what they did
to the president
is that they actually punished him for
behavior that occurred off of the
platform and peter tassly admitted this
in one of his answers to you andrew
when trump was actually removed from
twitter they cited two
specific tweets that he had sent that
occurred after
the capitol riot and claimed that he was
inciting further
violence but they had read that
incitement into the tweet it wasn't
actually there the first one that they
had a problem with was him
saying that he still believed the
election was stolen and the second one
is and i think this quote is pretty
accurate although
i'm paraphrasing slightly for those who
have been asking
i will not be attending the inauguration
on january 20th
that was the second tweet from the
president that they cited as
incitement of violence if you can be
punished for things that you say or
behavior that you engage in off of the
platform then that means the terms of
service
of these various social media platforms
are phony
is it well i was going to say if if you
can't take into account real life events
then i'm not sure we want anyone over
there trying to arbiter or or divine the
the interpretation of what donald
trump's tweets are
it was very clear that he continues to
perpetuate
this idea that he won this election in a
huge landslide and it's being stolen
from him and his fellow patriots
that's ludicrous he lost the election
everybody knows he lost the election
i'm almost a little bit worried thinking
that maybe he doesn't know i it was
either he's
completely delusional he might be the
one that doesn't know
he might be which i don't know what's
scarier uh if if this is a
he really believes this stuff b he was
just playing a game to raise money and
he doesn't like to lose
or see he really was plotting something
more nefarious right and i think it's
probably a combination of all three
but it's very clear what he's doing and
amber we knew where this would go
if you're part of a doomsday cult that
says january 15th the world is going to
end the sun rises on january 16th what
does everybody do
who has spent the last 6 12 24
48 months preparing for the end of the
world it's not coming
biden will be inaugurated on january
20th we've always known that
and for some reason a sizable percentage
of the american population
refuses to believe that reality because
they're being egged on
by by by by our leadership frankly
amber well if you knew that this was
going to happen then why did these
social media companies not ban the
president sooner why is there
retroactive action being taken
and i would also ask why there are
multiple tweets from democratic
officials that remain up
after the 2016 election where they were
questioning
whether or not that election was
legitimate
nancy pelosi has a tweet from 2017 for
example
where she says that this election was
not legitimate and that the president is
not the true president
so why is one of those inciting violence
and the other is not
well i think you've just answered your
question one of them did not incite
violence and the other one did first of
all
and second of all tweets from the
president that led to his suspension
were tweets that were characterized as
the having the potential to incite
violence
after a violent event had occurred in
the same way you could read the same
thing into pelosi's tweet
there were riots all over dc where
people were smashing store windows
and burning down the city during trump's
2016 inauguration
and pelosi was questioning the election
in 2017
so why was hers not given the same
characterization as the president's
because well i again i'll disagree and
i'll say hindsight's 2020.
and there have not been mobs of people
roaming the streets and certainly not
breaching
the the the sacred grounds of the u.s
capitol arguing that nancy pelosi or her
party should be
uh in charge of the white house that it
just didn't happen and this kind of both
sides ism
uh that we've gotten accustomed to i
think it hopefully also
uh will will die a death here but i'll
also note that in october 19th
i did write a piece in the washington
post calling for
facebook and twitter to mute the
president i considered calling on them
to mute
both the president and joe biden but i'm
not sure anybody is
reading joe biden's tweets as closely as
they're reading the president's they're
not quite as interesting
but they're also not inciting this type
of of nonsense and ignorance and
violence out in the country so
i would just disagree with with on the
face that i think that
uh what what people said about the
presidential election in 2016 first of
all there were investigations about it
so there was a
at least enough of it there there uh
where people did suspect that there was
some things going on that were not
uh above level uh but i'd also say that
there
was not violence there hasn't been
violence uh certainly not to this degree
i think what does concern people peter
though is the sense of unaccountable
power
whether you agree with what twitter has
done whether you think it's biased that
it tends to go for
those on the right rather than the left
the bigger issue is unaccountable
power uh particularly when they seem to
act in concert
i mean these are these are companies far
bigger
than the oil the railways the steel the
robber barns at the end of the 19th
century in america
they've got much more money and much
more influence
and yet twitter bans trump for life and
you've given the reason why and
incitement to violence is a is something
that has
there's not a right to that uh in free
speech
but trump's people then say all right
we're going to move to parlor
and we can do stuff there and then
immediately
the rest of big tech closes that down
as well the apps are you cannot get
either from google or from apple
and amazon says we ain't hosting you
anymore
that's a cartel in america
cartels are illegal
i think that's something that the new
congress both sides
have an interest in and the power of big
tech and whether
uh whether they're using that power
correctly or whether they should have
that much power
is something that should be looked into
and i have no doubt that it will be
investigated
ironically though should section 230 for
instance which provides these platforms
with
the the uh protection not to be liable
for everything
that people post ironically you remove
section 230
and parlor and gab are gone in 30
seconds i don't think they they want to
be held
liable for the information that's on
those platforms
and they'll learn how hard a job this is
to try to monitor it so so that's a
problem
and i and i hear your point when the
platform
said look we're not a newspaper we're
not i mean if we publish in the
spectator
an incitement to violence or or
something that's libelous or defamatory
or whatever
we are subject to the full force of the
law it can cost us a lot of money
the editor in some circumstances could
go to jail
the the social media platform said we're
not publishers
we're just a platform we're a neutral
platform
and so therefore we're not responsible
for what appears
but suddenly mr dorsey and mr
zuckerberger is saying actually we
are responsible that's why we're taking
the president
down because he's inciting violence it's
why we are
closing down parlor because it's full of
insidious toxic stuff
the moment you do that you need to be
regulated and subject to the law of the
land
i i'll quote senator mitt romney who at
one point
was looked upon favorably by the
republican party i'm not sure he is
by everybody anymore but he mentioned
that corporations are people in a
different context
corporations are people in that they are
made up of people making decisions
want to talk about the first amendment
the first amendment means being able to
say what you want and do business with
whom you'd like to do business with so
ultimately this was a choice
i i it is am i comfortable they all
acted in concert
no i'm not but i can say that my guess
is it's more about
you know one person making a decision
everybody else looking around and saying
those guys don't seem to want to do
business with people trafficking in
conspiracy theories nonsense lies and
violence
you know what we don't have to either
and in fact we may end up being liable
for it depending what happens in the
next congress so
the power of the tech companies must be
looked into i think
even they have called for zuckerberg you
mentioned he has called for regulation
he doesn't want to be put in this
position
uh in his own words let me go back to
amber
i mean don't don't the republicans only
have themselves
to blame they have been in a position
amber for the past four years
to do something about this uh maybe to
take a leap out of teddy roosevelt's
book he was a
republican president admittedly rather
different
more distinguished president than mr
trump but he was of the fortune along
with mckinley
as well of do of bringing in what became
the anti-trust legislation against the
robber barons in america
but amber the republicans did nothing
about this when they had the chance to
do it
you're exactly right andrew this is a
major failure of the republican party
there were whispers
about things like anti-trust regulation
or section 230 reform
by some members of the republican party
notably senator josh hawley
congressman matt gates but outside of
just a few republicans this was not
something that was very popular the cry
from
the free market conservatives was that
these are private companies and
therefore
they get to decide who is allowed on
their platforms but when these companies
start acting in coordination with one
another
and control so much of the internet that
they can summarily ban a competitor
then that's when you start to get into
an anti-trust situation
and in fact jack dorsey said in his
statement
explaining the banning of the president
from multiple platforms yesterday by
claiming that they had not acted in
coordination with one another
however twitter did say from their
public policy team
that when they were looking at
misinformation and the spread of
misinformation in the ugandan election
that they had all acted in coordination
i can't think of a better case that a
company would make against its own
monopolistic behavior
than what twitter admitted to just a
couple of days ago
peter let me finish with with you uh
the the democrats at the moment they now
control the white house
they've got a casting vote majority in
the senate they've got a smallish
majority
in the house but they're in charge of
these three key parts
of government they must think that so
far
the big tech people have censored those
that they think should have been
censored they're on the
way on the opposite side of the aisle
sometimes way out on the far
right bit of the aisle will they have an
appetite to do anything about
big tech in the next couple of years
i think they will i mean certainly
senator warren
has been very vocal on this was very
vocal on this during the campaign
uh as well as some other other more left
of center democrats in the senate in the
house
i think there there are concerns to be
raised this is not something that we've
seen
you know in a while in the united states
at least since we last took
antitrust action these are very very
large very powerful companies
who have gotten to a point where they
have such influence that i think that
the government
should take a look and and i think that
that will happen
um really regardless of who's in power i
think there's appetite on both sides now
but
you know you mentioned andrew when you
asked emperor uh do the republicans have
themselves to blame
uh and in this case i think the answer
is yes the republicans do have
themselves to blame they have not
been a responsible political party and
there's a reason why
their base has become unhinged from
reality
and they have a responsibility to tell
the truth to their base to stop the big
lie and hopefully that will improve the
situation in society
because ultimately social media is a
mirror of society
it's only going to be as good or as
truthful or as valuable as the people
who are posting on it
all right peter we'll leave it there uh
peter and amber thank you so much for
joining us i know it's early where you
are
in the morning and we're grateful for
your time and your contributions thank
you both
thank you for having me now remember if
you subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel
they haven't taken us off here yet it's
free and you'll never miss another
episode
just click the subscribe button at the
bottom right of the screen now
on to the pandemic it's always with us a
new strain yes a third one
is worrying government scientists it's
from brazil and the government's chief
scientific advisor admitted he didn't
know if our vaccines could protect
against it the government has come under
fire for reacting too slowly
to this new outside threat but it is
difficult these new threats seem to be
emerging all the time university college
london's professor francois balu
is one of the uk's leading experts in
genetics
his research lies at the intersection
between genomics
epidemiology evolution and ecology
so who better to shed light on this new
strain than him a professor welcome to
spectator
tv what can you tell us about this
new strain from brazil well we don't
know
that much about it it has some
similarities with the strain we've been
seeing in circulation
in south africa in particular it has
one mutation which is i would say the
mutation
we really worry a bit about in terms of
immune escape let's say how well
vaccines will protect against it i'd
really like to stress that it's not an
immune escape strain at this stage it
might just
reduce the efficacy of the vaccines a
little bit
tell us what's happening when when the
the these
these strains uh mutate
um am i right in thinking that the
this is part of their survival is that
why they mutate
yes so mutations tend to be random and
from the beginning of the panoramic
uh let's say initially we had very
little variation in the virus popular in
the viral population
and then diversity has been building up
some mutations and on average every
strain acquires about 25 mutations a
year
so most of them do absolutely nothing
they have no effect on
on the virus um they don't make it
transmit better they don't make it
escape vaccines or immunity
but then there are a few that can change
the virus
a little bit and we haven't seen much
happening
until very recently but over i would say
the last
weeks we have a few strains that seem to
be a bit
more different so there is clearly
evolution going on there
is one of the differences professor is
that
one or two of these new strains we think
of what for a while was called the
the the kent virus that it seemed to
spread more quickly
than the virus that we first encountered
in
march of this year yes there is some
good evidence that
this lineage which is um becoming
dominant in the uk
now is more transmissible than the ones
we had before
so it is not escaping immunity
it is a bit unclear how it does actually
transmit better
there's still some uncertainty how much
more transmissible it is so i think
we'll have to
wait for a few weeks to put an exact
number on it
but clearly it's gone up in frequency
quite drastically over the last weeks
and is it a rule of thumb or not
that when a virus mutates it may is you
as you say
it becomes more transmissible but does
it
does it weaken when it mutates
not absolutely necessarily so the only
thing that matters
for viral violence and actually
generally evolution
is how well it replicates so that's the
only
only selective pressure on it whether it
hurts us or doesn't hurt us
that's actually not so important for god
it's not important
it's obviously very important for us but
not for for let's say the selective
pressures on the valves
now less symptomatic
less aggressive strains could be favored
if they're not picked up people don't
feel ill people still move around
and they pass it on to others so that's
one mechanism by which viruses can
become more transmissible
but that's one of many and it's quite
difficult to make any predictions so
luckily this strain one seems to
transmit better
it doesn't seem it well it it
clearly doesn't create more severe
symptoms and not more lethal
and we'll have to wait for a little bit
to see what it might actually be
slightly milder
but for those of us who are not experts
on this the the thing that all work
immediately comes into our minds
when we read about some new strain of
the virus is
gulp will the vaccines that we're
putting
so much hope on now that's our kind of
get out of jail card
will the vaccines work against this new
strain
what's the story there so all the
evidence points to the vaccines work
working perfectly well against the
strain as well as against any other
strain so there's no
reason to believe that vaccine efficacy
would be
lower against the kent whatever you want
to call it
is that a general feature of of of
viruses
professor that that if you get a vaccine
against
i mean i suppose the biggest vaccine
we've ever had uh in this year was
against smallpox
um and i'm sure smallpox must have
mutated
in lots of different ways but in general
if you get a good vaccine that works
in general it should be able to cope
with the mutating a virus
yes and no so small boxes is a bit
different it's a very slowly evolving
virus it's a dna virus it's completely
different beast
i think here we what's probably more
comparable
is is is the flu so influenza
and these are viruses that evolve quite
quickly and
as we all know let's say the fluid jab
needs to be
redesigned on a regular basis so
essentially people the most at risk
they say get vaccinated each year and i
think we have to prepare ourselves
to have to update the vaccine which is
not the end of the world so that's
technically very easy to do we have
excellent surveillance in place so we
know
what we have what we what to expect we
know what strains are emerging we know
which ones are of concern and
in principle it won't be a major
challenge to have people
revaccinated on a regular basis it might
not be
every year but i would say every
probably three
four years we'll have to let's say we
vaccinate
the people who need to be vaccinated and
are we only clear on the week when the
who
investigators are arriving in china to
investigate the origins of the virus
in the work you've done on the genomic
data that you've been working
on too are we any clearer about the
origins of this virus
it jumped around october 2019
into the human population it might have
been around a little bit earlier but
let's say
all the strains with sequins so far
that's
350 000 essentially they all have an
ancestor which dates back to
october to around october 2019
and then it started spreading first
probably quite slowly
it reached italy quite early we have
good evidence that it was in italy in
november 2019
it wasn't really picked up initially and
then obviously as we all know
from late december january on we
realized
um there was a problem but by then it
was actually probably fairly widespread
at least in europe
sorry professor owen you go and then
obviously the question is
where did it come from um we know of
related fairly closely related viruses
that circulate in bats in
in china and the
we know actually have many of related
coronal viruses in all sorts of animal
populations bats carnivores even birds
and these things are are actually not
uncommon
and it can happen that they just jump
posts we also know that sarcophagu has a
very broad host range so we can infect
humans but it can
take prime it's gonna be cats and dogs
and
and and whatever what not
so i think the
the most likely um scenario is that
it was some kind of natural spillover
from an animal but then obviously
when well where did what and it probably
happened
in china very very likely happened
around october 2019
and then obviously did it go to a lab
let's say was it stored in a lab someone
got infected
this is very very difficult to say what
i'd like to stress is that
we really have no evidence that it was
kind of engineered
by some nefarious muffins so it looks to
me
very natural when i look at it align the
sequins
against loads of other corner viruses i
can see
nothing really super special about it so
they
i mean one of the extreme conspiracy
theories that we don't need to dwell on
is that
china essentially it uh intentionally
unleash this virus let's let's
park that the the official story for a
while was it came from the wet markets
and
almost naturally but wouldn't it also be
possible that the
the lab in wuhan was working
experimenting with this virus doing
perfectly legitimate
scientific research into it and and it
got out
somehow it just kind of it lost it
yeah i think we cannot rule this out at
this stage and i hope there will be a
proper investigation to clarify that but
even if it happened
to be absolutely brutally honest similar
things have happened before
and there's always a small risk that
let's say something can escape from a
lab
if i hope it won't happen and i hope we
will be more
careful in the future but these things
have happened in the past
there was some data i'd just like you to
to to mark our card on this from italy
we've got some people uh quite excited
in china
because it said the blood samples taken
in september had tested
positive for covert 19 antibodies and
the chinese societies say ah so it shows
that virus it didn't
originate with us if it was september
for those of us who are anything but
experts in this area
we just don't know what to make of that
what do you make of it yeah
there have been several similar claims
in the literature
including peer-reviewed journals um i
have to say that these studies were not
particularly carefully performed um
there's always a risk of false positive
this was
um let's say this kind of test and if
you just screen samples especially
all times they'll not be necessarily
concerned perfect conditions
you can pick up some false positives and
i wouldn't say the evidence
is convincing at all the really
convincing evidence we have
is for cases in december
and november in france and northern
italy
so actual cases there's one from early
november
child and it's pretty convincing that
this was an actual
and then we have some evidence from
wastewater also from northern italy
which suggests that it was in
circulation in december
interesting professor we the i think the
in this what i might call the second
wave the the number of cases
the huge rise and the number of deaths
has taken a lot of people by surprise
certainly a lot of non-experts by
surprise
from the government down and january and
february look like being pretty dark
days in britain and in other countries
too
our hope our optimism if there is any is
all around
the vaccine um as it's rolled out and we
in britain seem to be doing
pretty well compared to other countries
and rolling out that vaccine and
uh there's talk now that it could well
be about 19 million people
are getting it by the end of february
sometime into early march
up are we right to have that as
to regard that as the light at the end
of the tunnel and the light is
not an oncoming train
i i absolutely agree so the vaccine is
will be absolutely essential to bring us
back to normal but let's say
the vaccine is is a brilliant beautiful
tool that will
help us getting back to
meaningful normal life a bit sooner
but fundamentally pandemics come to an
end
now there's an
element of seasonality so i would say
many people predict it
actually this winter wave predicted this
winter wave to be more
severe than the spring wave so that
that's really in line with what we know
from
enveloped rna viruses which have this
highly seasonal behavior
they transmit best in dry cold air
and obviously
by transmitting the in fact people and
people
gain immunity now obviously at a
terrible cost
and by having also a fraction a large
fraction as large as possible population
being protected by the vaccine rather
than infection we obviously
decrease the burden quite dramatically
but that's really the burden
in terms of of mobility and mortality
but fundamentally the pandemic
would come to an end more let's say
there's no doubt about that we had we
have experienced previous pandemics
let's see influenza pandemics in 1918 57
68 the mild one in in 2009
but i say these it feels like the end of
the world but let's say
there's there's definitely light at the
end of the tunnel and and also
the vaccine use is wonderful and it will
accelerate
let's say the ending of the pandemic
well we'll keep our eye on that light
even if it still seems a little far
away at the moment professor thank you
for the work you're doing in
this area and for your expertise and for
sharing that with us
on spectator tv today thank you thank
you to you
bye thanks so professor
there uh let's go now to politics i
bring in our political team james
forsyth our political editor
uh at the spectator katie balls uh the
deputy political editor
james i come to you first on the
politics of it it's uh
as i was saying to the professor there
big number of cases
maybe flattening out now uh
big number of deaths as well another row
over school meals
but the vaccine rollout going pretty
well james where are we
what's the politics of this i think that
everything hinges on
the vaccine rollout the speed with which
that can happen
i think if you get to a situation where
the government can hit its target for
vaccinating 13 and a half million people
the most vulnerable by the middle of
february
and it's then vaccinating at a rate of 2
million people a week
that would suggest that you could really
massively significantly loosen up
restrictions
sometime in april looking at the uk
rollout compared to
other countries in europe you know the
uk eventually be able to come out of
restrictions
earlier if that happens i think that
would give people a much more positive
sense of the
government's handling of the pandemic
than they have today and i think people
would
because right now the numbers in terms
of the economic hit the death numbers
these are these are not good for the
government and
so the government needs a success story
on the vaccine uh
if it is to come out of this uh pandemic
in in in
in political shape the
scale of this second wave though seems
to have
shut up or should i put it another way
muted
the locked down skeptics on the tory
side though yeah
i i think you i mean you look at the
current numbers and the debates about
when
icu capacity might be overrun and it's
very hard to say that you should
adopt an approach of allowing people to
take them take their own judgments about
how much risk
i also think that the shift in the
swedish approach
that has underlined essentially the one
alternative model
for handling this pandemic indeed
katie uh preschool meals
back in the headlines again what is it
about this government
and free school meals yes
it's it's a hill where many say is this
the hill the government would choose to
die on
and because they often find themselves
in a situation where they
not even perhaps even defend their
policy but they sit there a bit
awkwardly
and then eventually forced into changing
it and it annoys a lot of the mps in the
process i think what we saw this week
relates to
hampers i don't think that these fit
what anyone would imagine is a
definition of a hamper
and but the actual food packages going
to those who
are on free school meals subpar below
the required and the suggested outline
of what is in them
i think when photos first surfaced on
social media with marcus rashford the
footballer once again leading the charge
initially a little bit of skepticism
actually from some on the tory side
suggesting this was you know
point scoring causing trouble but this
time i think a much quicker
uh response from the center in terms of
number 10 in
quite quickly saying oh we don't
recognize this we think this is very bad
too and then a strange sight
on wednesday at prime minister's
questions when boris johnson actually
praised marcus rashford for providing
the real opposition
suggesting that kierstarma wasn't as
effective as marcus rashford at
holding the government here count
pointing out when they had problems
so i was trying to spin it a bit i think
in terms of where we are now
you have a situation where the
government is obviously trying to blame
the companies on this
but now people are looking at the
government recommended amounts and
saying it's not actually that different
to what's in some of these pictures
people getting very angry about
but the government had when it was last
faced with this need to provide
with schools closed to provide lunches
for those who qualified for free school
lunches
it had a voucher system it didn't get
involved in
creating packages of food it sent out
vouchers which the parents
could then use to substitute for free
school meals
why did it not have that on the shelf
ready to run again
well i think that's what a lot of people
are asking and you saw when ministers
are trying to calm down this route they
said look the voucher system is nearly
coming into effect
just wait for the vouchers and they're
saying actually part of this is down to
choice but
i think there's clearly been an issue in
rolling that out at the right speed and
making sure that option is
clearly available to everyone and
therefore i think even though the
government is trying to say this row has
nothing to do with us i don't think that
is really washing with quite a lot of
people
james is the there's been talk uh if
this brazilian strain that i was
discussing
with the professor from ucl there if it
turns out to be
even more virulent in terms of
transmission than the
what we call the kent strain there may
have to be an even
tougher lockdown yet on the other hand i
see the number of cases
beginning to flatten out the london
hospital situation beginning to ease up
a bit
where do you think we'll go with this
stick with what we have
or possibility of even stricter lockdown
rules
so i think it's quite hard to tighten up
the current lockdown
rules without uh getting back into
making very difficult decisions saying
to people who live on their own for
example you just shouldn't expect to see
anybody
until uh for another month or so i think
that's quite a hard thing to ask people
to do
and i think i think the one of the
questions i think is one of the
political weaknesses for the government
here is
but you know there's been another
announcement of another delay in
uh testing requirements before people
enter the country i think people are
saying well hang on a second
there are all of these strains out there
that are causing
concern why is there not a stricter
testing and quarantining
regime at the uk's airports if you look
at those
asian democracies that has handled this
crisis so much better than the uk has
think of south korea
they've got far far stricter policies
around testing on arrival
and quarantining and i mean there is
there is puzzlement about
why wait you know why are we waiting for
um a cabinet committee meeting today
to move forward on on on banning travel
from uh flights coming in from brazil
why is this testing regime at the
airports not set up yet
and so i think that that is going to be
an issue for the government which is you
know
why why has the borders
you know that's one of the lessons from
march which clearly is that the uk kept
its borders open for too long
didn't have testing requirements for
people coming in you know i mean there
is a
there will be a real danger of the
government if that is repeated and you
end up with a new
uh more virulent more more transmissible
strain
being imported into the country and
restrictions having be
having to be tightened up again i mean i
think most people
would probably think that if you're
coming into the country
from wherever you may be coming from a
place where the
where where the epidemic is so high the
that travel
for the there should be no air corridor
from that place
but in general if you're coming in from
europe or north america or the far east
either you should have a a test
certificate that shows you were negative
taken in the last i don't know 48 72
hours
or you have to be tested immediately on
landing
but that's not the situation james is it
no not yet and i mean
there is i mean you know they've
announced another delay to that coming
in i think people are puzzled as to why
it has taken so long to get this kind of
airport testing regime
up and running and it's particularly
puzzling given that
the uk testing capacity is so much
greater now
than it was at the beginning of this
pandemic
so we would have the testing capacity i
saw somewhere
that um we have the ability we have the
capacity to do
700 000 tests a day
now given the number of people flying in
that would be and of course it's all
going to grow just on that
but clearly we have the capacity to do
this now i would have thought
yeah and and if you if you talk to
people who've traveled during this
pandemic
you know we are one of the laksa
countries in terms of
of the rules in terms of uh how much
uh where you can where you can
quarantine
when you need it whether you need a test
on arrival and there is
clearly a case for tightening that up
especially because i think one of the
things that
as you were saying about what's changed
the lock down skeptics might i think one
of the other things that has changed
tory mp's
minds on this who are more pragmatic is
one of the biggest threats to the
vaccine rollout program right now
is uh the disease getting out of control
again if you look at the regional
breakdown of stats andrew that's just
been released on where people have been
vaccinated
london is doing very badly and one of
the explanations for that is
that because the virus is so prevalent
or has been so prevalent in london
but that has made it harder to kind of
ramp up the vaccination program
and given the kind of economic and human
cost of staying locked down
clearly you should be doing everything
you can to try and get things back to
normal as quickly as possible
and one key part of that is controlling
the virus enough so that you can
vaccinate at at pace
katie finally looking uh at the vaccine
rollout i mean that there's a bit of
arguments about
who should be the next priorities and so
on and there's
gps saying they need more there's always
some wrinkles
but overall in my round of thinking that
so far so good yes i think as a broad
kind of judgment of where we are i think
that is where ministers feel as though
they are
and yes we are having complaints about
some of the bureaucracies still in place
if you look at pharmacies and and
getting out the vaccine
and the the spread across the country
why some places cannot get more vaccines
just because they've been perhaps
effective at getting out
but ultimately um yes publicly you keep
hearing ministers saying
not only have we done xx many vaccines
that is uh more than all these european
countries put together
very keen to land there but secondly i
only get the impression they're even
more optimistic privately than they are
publicly because there has been a switch
recently where this government has had a
reputation for
over-promising and under-delivering and
they are consciously trying
to do the opposite under promise over
deliver now
the jury's out on that but i do think
that actually when it comes to that
target and the pace
i think there's a lot of optimism that
they might actually go quite a bit
quicker
well it would be nice if they
under-promised and over-performed or
over-delivered for a change
that would be good we'll keep an eye on
it as the vaccine continues to be rolled
out across
the united kingdom james and katie
thanks for joining us
on spectator tv and we finish with
vaccines though because one country's
name has come up again and again
as a world leader in this vaccination
rollout against
the pandemic and that country is israel
he's managed to vaccinate a fifth of its
population already now it's a
small population compared to britain but
a fifth is still uh a lot
israeli journalist angel pfeffer writes
in the spectator this week that as
elsewhere the program in israel has
become political
uh because of course prime minister
netanyahu is heading
yet again for elections in march
andrew welcome to spectator tv let's
start with the vaccination
program tell us what's been happening in
israel and
and why israel seems to be doing really
pretty well in this regard
well the rollout began almost four weeks
ago and
since the rollout has been uh organized
by the four israeli public health funds
which
are in a competition with each other and
they have a very
very strong connections with their
members that
the the the amount of vaccinations that
they've been able to carry out in this
time is quite
is quite high they've opened hundreds of
vaccination centers across the countries
in
in their clinics in hospitals even in
especially
set up compounds for vaccinations and
it's been
it's been working seamlessly almost for
four weeks now and there's uh
there's a very there's a very high
public awareness and every
each of these four funds and you know
you have to imagine that that you've got
something like the nhs but four times
over
and four nhs is meeting with each other
to roll out the vaccine
as fast as possible for its members and
that's that's a major element of why
it's been happening
now like he said i want to come back to
that structure because it is
interesting to have kind of four nhs is
competing
but let me as opposed to our monopoly of
in the nhs but let me come back to to
some of the details first of all
what vaccine uh are they using
they've been using the fi the fisa bio
and tech and there there has been a
shipment of modern vaccines as well but
right now
they're focusing on the fisa one and are
they
is the policy there all these questions
as you as you'll understand are relevant
to
what's happening in the rest of europe
and the united kingdom
are are they concentrating as seems to
be the case now in britain of getting
people
get them a first vaccine and worry about
a second vaccine later
no every israeli who goes in to get the
first jab
goes out with already with a print out
of an appointment
three weeks hence and quite a quite a
large number already got the second jab
there was a discussion here in israel
over the last few weeks whether to go
down the same path as britain
and first of all try and jab as many
people as possible with the first job
they decided that since
the cooperation with pfizer is working
well and pfizer is
shipping a sufficient number of doses to
israel over the over the time
and the logistics chain is working well
there's no reason
not to adhere to the protocol of having
the second jab for three weeks
are we seeing some of israel's
huge assets coming into play here
uh you know it has uh you know it is the
silicon valley
valley of the of your part of the world
indeed of the
hemisphere it's a huge advanced i.t
and in biotech he's got an incredibly
efficient military
he's got a a wonderful industry
has this all come into play to help
in the vaccine effort well andrew you
mentioned
two assets you mentioned the high-tech
community and you mentioned the military
yes when it comes to high-tech now in
the vaccine effort that certainly has
been a major element because we
mentioned the four health funds each of
these health funds are very much
invested in out through in digital
outreach to patients
so patients have their medical records
their doctors fi
their doctor records going back 20 years
all within the year they can just touch
a keyboard and they can get it it's all
on they they all have customized apps on
their smartphones from whatever health
and they're working for
so they have this very high level of
engagement
with their with their gps with their
clinics and they can be called in
very easily very quickly for vaccines
and they're even cases where people have
received an appointment for in a week or
two and suddenly they'll
get a phone call actually we have a load
of acts of doses right now in the clinic
and we want to make sure that we use all
of them
can you come in earlier can you come in
another half an hour can you come in
this evening
many people have been vaccines in that
way because and
that is that is really very much to do
with the technology because
the level of contact is so high and the
technology gives something else it gives
pfizer
a chance to observe an entire
uh an entire population being
being vaccinated almost in real time
because so much of the data is
available to the israeli health
authorities
and part of the deal with fisa where
under which fires has agreed
to give it to early shipments of the
vaccine includes
also access to this data there's
obviously there are concerns about
about patient privacy here as well but
for fighters
this was a this is a very good
opportunity to see how well their
vaccine is working not just in the
trials
that they've carried out until now but
in an actual 9 million
size population with different kinds of
groups different ages
different health conditions and so on so
that so technology has been a big part
the military which was involved in
different parts of the pandemic before
that in
trying to set up the contact racing for
example that has been less successful
they're involved in a small way in the
vaccination drive they're providing
transport they're providing in some
places medics but that's a small
that's a small part it's really mainly
been done by the civilian public health
funds
interesting because the the military
here i think's had to play a bigger role
but your health system
perhaps doesn't need the military in the
way that uh britain has needed
help well a country there's only one
logistical
storage center near the airport when the
when the doses are flown in from belgium
where they're manufactured
and it's a matter of hours to ship them
to any part of the whole country
i understand tell us a bit about this um
the four
publicly funded uh health systems and
how that operates in general the
principle is still like the nhs that
health is is free at the point of
delivery
yeah there's a very there's a very tiny
almost symbolic fee that you pay for
for a doctor's visit it's usually about
equivalent of two or three pounds so
it's
that's that's not a major issue but by
and large
it's it's almost free at the point of
delivery but instead of having one
service but
for political and historic reasons
because the health funds were originally
set up by political parties or by
workers unions
four of them still exist and they
basically divide the entire population
between them now as an israeli citizen
you have the right
to choose your fund and you can move at
any time most people don't want to move
because
you've got your gp you've got you know
your clinic and so on
but you have you have the ability to
move and that keeps
this kind of tension of competition
between the four funds
and like i said this is this kind of
created an ecosystem where
delivering vaccines very quickly was
relatively simple
and i mentioned that you it looks like
israel has done about a fifth of its
population i think the population of
israel
is just a little bit over 9 million do
you have any idea then when
the whole population will be vaccinated
well obviously they're not vaccinating
children now but
they want to reach sort of two-thirds of
the grown-up population by the end
of march and that is very conveniently
also when israel is holding
its next election indeed and i want that
that's going to be my final question but
before i do
uh the arab population in israel
palestinian population and so on
that i assume is all part of this uh
vaccination
uh early israel's arab citizens living
within
what's called the green line or the
pre-1967 borders
are israeli citizens they've received
vaccinations like everyone else
also the three hundred thousand
palestinians living in east jerusalem
which is under israeli control they're
not citizens but they have
full access to israeli health care so
they also
are vaccinated the five million
palestinians living in the west bank
and gaza under different it's arguable
what the level of military occupation
there is
are under the responsibility of the
patenting authority
and there is a there is an art there is
a legal argument of
what israel's responsibility is behind
the scenes
israel is working with the palestinian
authority to help them get vaccinated as
well but because of lots of political
reasons nobody wants to say out public
that israel is
taking care of them it's not good for
antonio's politics
interesting and finally then the
election yet another one i've lost count
number four and also the results are so
complicated
as well when you get them and takes ages
so there's another one on march the 23rd
mr netanyahu who's had his troubles um
and hasn't been a clear victor in recent
elections
i assume this vaccination program must
be a help to the incumbent prime
minister
well since we're in a pandemic there are
no political
rallies but the prime minister can and
does
take television crews with him every day
to another vaccination center
sometimes he goes to the airport to
greet a big crate of
uh of those is coming from belgium it's
it's basically his entire campaign he
even changed
the banner on his twitter account the
other day from a photo of him together
with donald trump which is not so
it's a bit toxic now so a photo of him
being jabbed by his own personal doctor
that is netanyahu's campaign i am the
one bringing israel
out of the pandemic i am delivering
israel thanks to my incredible
connections overseas i've
brought all these doses on time you know
it almost
says it as if he paid for them himself
though obviously his taxpayer money
and netanyahu's re-election campaign is
vote for me i'm the national vaccinator
tell me this just final uh thing because
we saw a different approach to
peacemaking in the middle east under mr
trump
uh and he whether it was him himself as
the administration it brought together
the
sunni arab gulf states and in israel
as well it did not include the
palestinians in the
the peace uh process and there was a
general
fear that the common enemy was israel
was iran
uh for the sunni arabs and for israel
itself
it was very much a product of the trump
years
is there a fear and so far it's bahrain
i think has recognized you
uh the uae
and and and exactly and there could be
more coming uh
as well morocco sudan yeah for
four arab states exactly so
is there a worry in israel that the
biden administration might not
continue down this road there is a
concern certainly
within the danielle government because
there are a number of parameters that
change under trump first of all
barack obama tried to sort of balance
america between the sunni states
and shia iran while trump firmly put his
focus on
on alliances with the season with israel
at iran's expense so this like you said
there was this creation of the joint
enemy
and there's also the palestinian issue
since the trump administration didn't
really care for the palestinians
the whole diplomatic orthodoxy that
existed for decades that first of all
israel needs
to achieve a breakthrough with the
palestinians and only then
israel will have peace with the wider
arab world that paradigm has changed
with our arab states making peace with
israel without
waiting for any progress on the
palestinian front now that may change
under the
administration if they change america's
diplomatic priorities in the middle east
well we shall see it'll be a fascinating
uh story as it develops uh
angel thanks for joining us on spectator
tv
uh thank you for the article you wrote
for the spectator this week which is
excellent i recommend
everybody have a look at it for giving
us your time today
thank you bye bye now that's it for this
week thanks to our other guests as well
of course
and a very special thanks to our sponsor
charles stanley
continuing to sponsor the week in 60
minutes charles stanley
is one of the uk's leading wealth
management firms one of the oldest firms
on the london
stock exchange we are at the spectator
delighting to have charles stanley as
our partners in this television venture
now final reminder that if you subscribe
to
the spectators youtube channel and you
should it's free
you'll never miss another episode
because you just click the subscribe
button at the bottom right of the screen
now and you'll get warnings as to when
the next edition of spectator tv
is coming up as always send us any
thoughts you may have to spectator tv
at spectator dot co dot uk we read them
all
join us again next week thanks for
watching
[Music]
you